attack on titan has made its way back
onto the airways and with its most
recent episode being on imdb's list of
the highest rated television episodes of
all time along with its consecutive
compatriots season 3 episodes 16 and 17
the season is starting off very strong
to say the least
the return to paradise island and shigun
china brings up both nostalgia and new
feelings in fans
yet another battle between aaron and
reiner the star-crossed lovers i mean
friends i mean enemies the shift of
sides not knowing who's the enemy here
and what our goals are
the show truly leaves us in awe with
every new episode
it seems that for the most part concerns
regarding animation and cg that flooded
the internet at the beginning of season
4 a bit over a year ago have dissipated
and once that dust settles fans have
thankfully realized that when all is
said and done attack on titan is attack
on titan
but amidst the news articles released
every week about the groundbreaking
series it's it's almost impossible to
ignore a prevalent question and topic of
discussion
will attack on titan season 4 have a
different ending from the manga
if you haven't seen anyone talking about
this topic let me give you a quick
spoiler spoiler-free of course breakdown
of the whole situation
and if you do comment on this video do
try and preface or simply avoid manga
spoilers thank you
the final chapter of attack on titan was
released in april of last year and it
was very
very divisive so divisive that thousands
of attack on titan fans erupted across
twitter and the rest of the internet and
even went so far as to sign a petition
on change.org for isayama to write a
satisfying alternative ending to aot a
bit absurd isn't it
likewise in the aforementioned concerns
about the cg in the show last year we
saw people sending mass hate to mapa the
company animating the last season
but i
digress with most of that in the past
now what is concerning is the future of
the series more specifically the future
of the anime
making anime original endings is
something anime fans are no stranger to
as there's a rather prolific and
actually notorious track record of them
2003's fullmetal alchemist is arguably
the most famous example
after its first couple episodes the
series diverged heavily from the source
material because the manga was not
finished yet at the time and they ended
up creating their own ending
and though this original anime series
wasn't nearly as successful as its
incredible older brother fullmetal
alchemist brotherhood the one anime that
shadows over it and all anime for that
matter as what is generally referred to
as one of the best of all time the
original full metal alchemist on its own
wasn't that bad
in my opinion of course
likewise k on is probably the best
example of a series that not just
diverged from the manga but essentially
expanded on it and improved on it in a
number of ways
but the list of those that ended poorly
is far more extensive than the ones that
ended well
claymore ditched the manga ending and
finished its animated adaptation with a
rushed final battle
soul eater went as far as completely
changing character arcs and shifting
their sides and development
famed as one of the most disappointing
endings to an anime adaptation ever
and the very recent promised neverland
season 2 ending wasn't just a bad
adaptation but a horrible season all
around that completely tarnished the
reputation of a show that had an
incredibly promising and beloved first
season
there are many reasons a show goes anime
original the manga isn't finnish people
generally don't like the manga ending or
just a decision by the animation studio
just a unilateral choice independent of
the mangaka's opinion
but the second one here is what we're
focusing on with attack on titan
now the big question do i think they
should change the ending or that they
even will
no i don't
mapa by all means could a surprise anime
original ending if done right would
surprise anime original viewers and
manga readers alike boost the season's
attention and popularity and potentially
satisfy the many dissatisfied former
manga readers
but the key word here is of course
if done right
if it isn't then attack on titan will
forever be known not just for one
disappointing ending but two
also along with the flack map i received
last season for its adaptation i
wouldn't be surprised if fans worldwide
expressed their outrage against them
once again for changing the ending
even if they didn't like the original
ending that much
just the concept of changing the ending
and it's still being terrible or
potentially even worse
is worse than sticking to the original
material
with chainsaw man hell's paradise and
attack on titan on mapa's plate among
other huge names mappa doesn't have the
resources to deal with even more fan
critiques in all honesty let alone
allocating time and effort to thinking
up a completely different ending to the
biggest anime in the world
there's just too many reasons not to do
it and it really just wouldn't make
sense
and most important of all in my opinion
is that they respect the wishes of
isayama the author
isaiah does know about fan
disappointment in the ending
last year in isaiah's interview with
kodansha the series publisher he
discussed the ending in depth
he realized that the climax was a very
difficult theme for him to draw so he
regretted not being able to express it
properly in the manga
he thought he would please everyone with
the final chapter so he's sorry to those
that he disappointed yet thanks them for
the support
it's common among tv shows anime
media in general to have a rushed ending
try to wrap up all the pieces together
and it kind of falling apart at the end
and attack on titan unfortunately isn't
an exception here
and considering the effort mapa has
already made into adapting isayama's
work properly everything they've done so
far with season four part one and season
four part two it's it's just very
unlikely in my eyes that they would
stray away from it with such a huge
franchise
and i will acknowledge that perhaps
there's bias here because if you've been
with my channel for a while or watched
my video way back in april of last year
i posted a pretty long video talking
about the final chapter and personally
i liked it
there were parts i loved more than
others there were things that surprised
me and things that didn't
it it wasn't perfect but in my opinion i
enjoyed it and felt reasonably satisfied
with the series tenure as a long time
reader of about five years attack on
titan was one of the very first mangas i
actually started and
to be completely frank
i left the last chapter satisfied with
where the journey left us
but again that's just my opinion
what do you guys think about the
possibility of an anime original ending
do you want it and if you do do you
think that it can succeed
leave your thoughts
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyses
you